well let's bring in fox news senior
strategic analyst general jack keane
general
size this up for us uh we're starting
off this week they're having discussions
in geneva that started last night and
that will continue through the week what
do you make of it
well first of all as indicated
there's a lot of separation here on
these issues to be sure but there is a
possibility that
there could be an agreement and and
here's what would have to happen for
certain for that to take place
is the french and the germans would have
to absolutely be on the same page
with the americans and they have been
softer on russia
after all was the germans that initiated
the north stream two pipeline it became
so controversial to europeans and the
united states and macron and france has
also taken softer positions if they're
on the same page with the americans and
they're willing to impose these
significant international
economic sanctions on on russia and also
wanting to put additional troops into
nato countries as a result of an
invasion plus some
other things that the united states has
put on the table
then
putin may be convinced that this cost is
too great he is seeking an opportunity
here dana based on what he sees as
weakness
weakness because of the political and
social divisions in europe and in the
united states and weakness of what he
perceives in the white house as a result
of the afghanistan
decision certainly he was here in the
spring
with 70 80 000 troops he's back with 110
000 in the fall and what happened in
between the withdrawal and the debacle
of afghanistan i think putin sees
opportunity here we've got to stand up
to him it's our resolve
and determination that will be on the
table which putin will be looking at
closely can i ask ask you then this
uprising in kazakhstan which as uh now
they've called russian troops in to help
them quell that uprising do you think
that makes putin more or less likely to
want to flex some muscle in ukraine
well i think it adds to his credibility
because
what happened remember ukraine
what happened there is the people threw
out his stooge
the government of yanukovych just
literally ran him out of the country
and what happened in belarus
putin put forces into belarus after the
people are on the streets
trying to run that dictator out as a
result of a lousy election also and here
we have a similar issue in kazakhstan
and what putin is going to do is always
support the government in place which
are largely stooges for him
against the people and clear those
streets even if it takes a lot of
violence i think it adds to his
credibility that he's going to continue
to put pressure on ukraine
okay well we will pay attention to all
of it i'm sure we'll see a lot of you
this week as it moves along thank you
general hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now